ich weiß nicht ob das lesen können aber
schaut euch das an hey leute was genau
jetzt bekommen bahre video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich dass focus ich hab
natürlich geht's gut heute will ich
wirklich mal richtig stellt zum thema
kommen bevor es losgeht wollte ich
allerdings sagen gestern wurde das
iphone verlost im video gestern jemand
kurz aus schnipsen kann ich immer noch
nicht die haben ja ein iphone 8 eben
space cowboys oder wie das heißt bis auf
jeden fall ein cooles handy ist ja die
letzte sache aus wenn man bands gelandet
die jetzt verlost wird ja bei dieser
sache bringt ja persönlich vorbei
geschaut dass das video und schaut euch
dann danach das video von gestern an ich
verlinkt solche auch in der beschreibung
oder habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon unten
am titel gesehen und zwar muss ich erst
mal sagen ich habe letztens auf meine
starts heute gesehen ein video von dgb
und zwar hier ist das irgendwie meine
zeug das ich hab mal reingeschaut und da
gehört halt einfach ihre zeugnisse
gezeigt also deswegen bin ich auf diesem
video idee gekommen und zwar bin ich
jetzt schon ungefähr einem jahr nicht
mehr in der schule habe ich schon etwas
länger alter also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen schule ist schon was cool ist
irgendwie natürlich gibt es auch dinge
die man nicht vermisst aber ich finde
auch dass es sehr viele sachen gibt die
halt schon cool fand man bei mir was zum
beispiel soll ich war vier jahre in der
grundschule und dann noch weitere acht
jahre auf der weiterführenden schule und
ich war durchgehend halten mit den
gleichen leuten zusammen und dann
wechselt so zusammen und machten halt
zusammen den abschluss also es war schon
cool deswegen genießt auf jeden fall
eure schulzeit die zeit danach wird auch
nicht unbedingt besser außer natürliche
seit youtube spaß so in dem heutigen
video soll es natürlich um eine zeugnis
zu geben
ich weiß wirklich echt nicht mehr genau
natürlich weiß ich was ich will
abschluss hatte also ich hab ihr abitur
gemacht aber was ich in der fünften
klasse oder in der dritten klasse oder
in der zehnten klasse hatte weiß ich
eigentlich gar nicht mehr ich habe hier
unten alle meine zeugnisse liegen und
wir schauen jetzt zusammen aber gleich
darauf des weiteren würde ich dann auch
noch ein paar andere punkte eingehen die
halt auch schule betreffen was ich so
machen musste mit das was gebracht und
hat mir das nichts gebracht also dinge
die ihr auch sicherlich alle in der
schule machen müsste man das team der
schule sind die aus der schule raus und
vielleicht interessiert ihr euch dafür
mein zeugnis durch stand also ich will
gar nicht eingeladen
ich würde sagen ich gucke mal nach was
wir ja
so das hier ist mein abschlusszeugnis
das legt erstmal zur seite hier haben
wir zehnte klassen er dass mir auch zu
früh die haben wir 13 alter schuljahr
2006/2007 ja ich war der cd das c steht
für cool fünf und haben wir noch 7 a
ich würde sagen wir fangen aber mit dem
zeugnis aus der dritten klasse an bei
uns war es auch so die dritte klasse war
die erste klasse wo man wirklich ein
richtiges zeugnis bekommen haben wie
auch alle anderen schüler also da war
ich richtig stolz drauf
ich komme mit polnischen also leute die
wir machen nicht dritte klasse machen
vierte klasse bei der vierten klasse hat
dann bei uns dazu entschieden kommt man
aufs gymnasium kommt man auf die
realschule kommt man auf die hauptschule
habe ich auch schon wieder zugemacht mal
ganz ehrlich in der vierten klasse ist
man zehn jahre alt oder so da kann man
nur noch kein mensch sagen ob man später
schlau ist oder nicht ich finde das
irgendwie viel zu früh um irgendwelche
kindern zu teilen wie schlau sie sind
aber na ja bei mir ich war in der
vierten klasse war ich war richtig gut
leistungsbereitschaft zuverlässigkeit
selbstständigkeit das lasse ich mal
außen vor dass blogger mensch also bei
uns gab es elf fächer und ich habe in
lesende 1 ich habe in mathe nein ich
habe in sachen unterrichten 1 und ich
habe einen sportler 1 ich weiß ja wie
das lesen können aber schaut euch das an
das müsste dann im schnitt von ungefähr
1,6 sein das ist ein schnitt von 1,63
und das war dann wohl auch der beste
schritt meiner schulkarriere er da war
ich ja richtig gut doch ich bin dann
aufs gymnasium gekommen und ich hatte
auch eigentlich nur fünften klasse noch
gute noten aber dann hatte ich auch
schon mal eine drei in politik und
englisch hat es nur für eine 3 gereicht
dafür ein deutscher eins und sport1 ja
sport konnte ich echt immer richtig gut
vor allem früher hatte zwar in der
fünften klasse hatte ich dann nur noch
einen schnitt von 2,0
aber das war eigentlich auch ganz gut so
dann gehen wir weiter in die siebte uhr
hey wie sportler und gut
ach ja das lag an der lehre in der
siebten klasse hatte ich einfach gar
keine 162 versäumte stunden was hatte
ich dann heute schreibt bei euren rekord
an versäumten stunden pro halbjahr in
die kommentare mein rekord liegt
anscheinend bei 62 alter das waren da
los in der fünften hatte ich einfach
null versäumte stunden davon
unentschuldigt 0 in der siebten 62 davon
unentschuldigt 0 in der 12
die locker 80 davon unentschuldigt
eigentlich auch locker 50
weil es die lehrer dann auch nicht mehr
interessiert hat er an der siebten just
im ersten halbjahr hatte ich einen
schnitt von ungefähr 2,4 also irgendwo
dich immer schlecht da im zweiten
halbjahr hatte ich dann wenigstens
wieder nur einzeln sport aber auch
deutlich mehr drin was ich mich eben
auch gefragt habe ich hatte einfach drei
zeugnisse aus der sechsten das kann aber
gar nicht sein weil es ja nur zwei
halbjahre gibt so das springen wir
wollen die 19
da gab es dann die erste vier in
philosophie vier ich war ein philosophie
am ende eigentlich das war mit mein
bestes fach da hatte ich nur eins - und
daran hält man richtig es macht auch
sowas aus was man von durchschnitt hat
ob die lehre euch mögen oder nicht das
ist einfach so meine ich hatte hier in
der neunten klasse ebenso eine
kugelrunde lehrerinnen die mittel schon
rausgegangen ist kopieren hat sich dann
brötchen vom kiosk holten das vor der
klasse gefressen und die gib mir deine 4
jetzt muss ich mal kurz meinen
durchschnitt hier berechnen 3 er sollte
da warst du dann noch 2,7 so dann bin
ich in die zehnte gekommen und ich
glaube in der zehnte habe ich jetzt
nicht so viel für die schule zu machen
erneuten war ich auch nur 21 stunden
nicht da herausgehalten habe in der zeit
und passt auf deutsch englisch vier
spanisch 26 schoss gracias kunst 2 geo
verstehe ich gar nicht geschichte drei
philosophie 1 habe ich ja gesagt hatte
3m 3m chemie war seit der zehnten klasse
so ein phänomen für mich
das war das einzige fach wo ich wirklich
gar nichts verstanden habe ich habe
wirklich nichts verstanden ich habe auch
nicht verstanden wie man da irgendwas
verstehen kann ich weiß bis heute nicht
mal wie man millionen schreibt und erst
recht nicht was ihnen sind und ich hatte
einfach nur drei informatik 2 sport2 da
die sport schon schriftlich das sagt
daran darf ich mich schon wieder
gesteigert auf 2,6 so hier habe ich
irgendwann zertifikat gefunden das ist
wirklich der größte mühe eines kann ich
euch sagen all diese veranstaltungen von
der schule aus wo es darum gehen soll
was sie in der zukunft macht zum
beispiel hier abitur und wie weiter oder
realschulabschluss und weiter ich weiß
nicht wie es halt wenn es sich lohnt
krank zu sein dann macht sarah oder geht
einfach nicht hin das war wirklich so
eine zeitverschwendung ich war in der
oberstufe jedes
ja irgendwie zweimal in diesem witz das
ist halt die agentur für arbeit da geht
es dann halt darum ja was macht man denn
in der zukunft für welchen job ist man
geeignet und so weiter kleines beispiel
müsst euch so vorstellen alle sitzen vor
seinem computer machen so ein programm
da werden fragen gestellt was kannst du
gut bist du sportlich hast du gute
sozialkompetenz jaja kannst du gut mit
kindern umgehen ja dann kommt raus nun
der doch sportlehrer irgendwelche
menschen die nichts im leben erreicht
haben und euch denn sagen wollen was ihr
in der zukunft machen sollte das muss
ich jetzt einfach mal sagen weil es mich
immer so aufgeregt hat so dann kommen
wir zu einem abschlusszeugnis es ist
jetzt nicht mein abiturzeugnis aber ich
weiß dass mein abiturzeugnis und das
zeugnis genau den gleichen schritt
hatten ich habe abitur gemacht mit 2,36
auf jeden fall für mich nun ziemlich
akzeptabler durchschnitt ich habe schon
hin und wieder für die schule gelernt
war allerdings niemand der sich da jeden
tag wirklich hinter gesetzt hat und den
heftigsten schnitt rausfahren wollte
meine ich hatte da schon youtube
nebenbei und es war immer sehr stressig
vor allem weil ich echt manchmal in
dieser abitur phase immer so bis 1618 in
der schule saß und dann auch videos
machen
das war schon anstrengend verfolgen das
deutsch drei englisch drei kunst zwei
geografie 2 - geschichte 2+
sozialwissenschaften 2+2 chemie 3-format
x2 und sport hatte ich auch schriftlich
aber sogar nur 2 + ich kann man halt auf
diese 2,36 waren es glaube ich und so
sieht ein vor abitur zeugnis aus das war
echt immer witze ich habe hier zum
beispiel draufstehen versäumte stunden
im halbjahr 38 und ich muss wirklich
sagen so fächer wo es den lehrer
eigentlich gar nicht mehr interessiert
hat wäre da ist und wer nicht ich meine
wer alt genug der dann auch keine
entschuldigung haben wollte da war ich
echt selten also ich war lokal bei
fächern wo es um nichts mehr geht war
ich auch fast nie mehr da am ende
sondern halt nur bei den sachen die
wichtig waren dafür habe ich dann lieber
auch zu hause in der zeit gelernt also
versäumte stunden eigentlich locker 80
90 würde ich schon sagen manchmal hat
man halt auch mal ausgeschlafen aber
leute wenn ihr das macht erst wenn ihr
auch alt genug dafür seit das selber
einschätzen können und auch einigermaßen
guten der schulseite dann ist das finde
ich ok ja das war meine zeugnisse ich
habe mich von lackierten erst gesteigert
dank nicht wieder bergab und am ende wo
es darauf ankam bin ich jetzt bei meinem
2,364 landet ihr könnt ihr euren besten
zeugnis steht in die kommentare
schreiben und vielleicht auch europa
sollten stunden wir sehen uns dann schon
morgen wieder morgen
das video hat rein